Kyle Kolinski who's the owner of the
secular talk Channel on YouTube Kyle put
out a video titled Matt Walsh's fascist
mask slips on Twitter and he's part of
the mob terribly upset about my comments
though he liked the rest of them can't
quite explain why Singapore is able to
have nice things in part because they
execute drug dealers by hanging
and arrest even Petty vandals and
thieves and beat them with a cane until
they bleed we don't have nice things
because we aren't willing to do what is
required to maintain them there are some
accusing me of advocating similar laws
in this country and I just want to
clarify that yes absolutely I want those
laws in this country Matt Walsh is an
authoritarian you hate Freedom you hate
Liberty he's saying execute drug dealers
you want to start go find the CEO of
Pfizer okay sounds good to me I mean
yeah we have to give the big Pharma
Executives a fair trial of course
convict them in a court of law but once
that's been done I absolutely would want
them to face the same penalty that
should be imposed on any other drug
trafficker